[Music]
in my bad news
it's been my flash mob a woman
accidentally stole someone's car for two
weeks thinking it was her rental I get
it yeah I've almost gotten into other
people's cars so many times I've done it
what really yeah it opened up oh shoot
your remote or the key key when Marilyn
were going to San Diego we stopped at a
Tesla charger and it was the execs I
haven't put my license plate on my car
Oh like three of the exact same ones and
I thought my car was the one at the far
end it wasn't I kept doing this to get
that handle out excuse me look it scared
the [ __ ] out of me dude it was at night
too how long does it take to charge that
thing because you lost me in 30 minutes
oh [ __ ] that so what you're going from
San Diego San Diego and you have to let
go I need a 30 minute pitstop well it
takes 30 minutes to target all the way
so if you if you charge it for like 15
minutes it's already like a hundred
miles that it's all coming took you 18
hours to get to Vegas again cuz we
stopped by places Oh cuz he's romantic
I see cuz whoever was waiting for him
and we're like nobody was waiting you
weren't waiting for everyone's like this
in their hotel room
yeah really weak okay did anyone call
David abso-fucking-lutely nut yeah you
[ __ ] filthy desert Adam you know that
good meme where the girls all dressed up
and just sitting on the bed and she's
like waiting for her friends to pick my
battles all of us yeah all of us when I
walk through the suite I better have saw
some melted [ __ ] candles men and some
[ __ ] mascara dripping off your face I
see [ __ ] you see Gina that's a gentleman
[Laughter]
thanks a lot gotcha Gina can't defend
yourself that's how I like it I love
that so this story takes place in
Ontario so this woman she got a Nissan
rental excellent choice Versa a leaf
Sentra Sentra
okay and so right after she got her
Nissan she went into Walmart and then
she was shopping for a little bit and
then she ended up taking a black
Infiniti wait what
how could you get
the qx50 crossover quicks 450 what
though she got that looks nothing alike
I can see the same that's like Toyota
I'm going to Alexis yeah but that's a s
that's a Cu vivo even hers he's say that
me exactly so all right so she it was
like one of those key fob things where
you never actually need it because
that's how all cars are not yeah
and so she never really looked at the
keys um or she never thought twice about
it but she could have sworn that that
parking spot where that Infiniti was was
her rental car so she drove it around
for two weeks she even complained to the
manager of their car rental place like
like why are you giving like why did you
give me such a dirty car there's even
golf clubs in the back like she's a
[ __ ] idiot dude wait how did she
start the car though the guy left his
key in the Infiniti oh my god what are
the chances or she probably saw that
people like that do that there's people
she left her key
whenever I ever done that you said you
left your keys in LM only got a haircut
and the car was on the whole time
exactly it's way different I actually
had the key in the ignition I turned it
stupid anyway see ya thank you Steve
here you brother yeah Jesus I do the
show time so she left her car on - no so
what happened was when the guy came out
of Walmart she was like what the hell
like what happened to my car it's
missing so he ended up calling the
police and he went to that exact same
enterprise and he was telling this
manager like oh man someone stole my car
that's why I have to get this rental or
whatever so then a few days after that
or obviously two weeks after that that's
when the woman went back and was
complaining about the car and she saying
like that you know and I don't need this
car anymore or whatever well we tended
that she returned the car after using it
and then he rents his own car
[Music]
oh yeah but nothing the manager when she
was when he was talking to this woman
he ended up remembering about that other
guy that had his car stolen he was like
wait let me see your key the key thought
sink and it was a Nissan and then he was
like this is an Infiniti like that's not
your car so then he was like all right
take me to Walmart and show me the exact
spot where you parked and so they went
to Walmart and sure enough the Nissan
was still there oh oh with holding the
key so the car was never locked then the
car the keys were just somewhere in the
car she's [ __ ] dumb because I don't
even think a Nissan Sentra has the
starts not being missing I guess it does
cuz she it was the perfect storm too
because you can leave a dead body in
Walmart you know parking lot for you
know three years and nobody will know
sometimes I see these dusty-ass cars and
parking lots that look like they've been
there for three years or more and by the
way a Nissan Sentra is like smaller than
a Corolla so how the [ __ ] did she
confuse that it's a rental man she don't
know the car and it's also higher
because one's an SUV and the other ones
not [ __ ] though is the trash and the
golf clubs and she goes someone's gotta
[ __ ] tell about this [ __ ] why'd
you give me a dirty car yeah yeah
straight to that like cigarette butts in
there that would immediately been the
first thing where I'm like this is not
my car what the [ __ ] there's what if
there was paper is in the yeah because
the stupid thing is she [ __ ] got in
the car and drove it right so so
obviously she didn't notice all the
trash and then when she got in there's
magically trash now maybe she's not a
present type of person yeah she was
thinking about the divorce that she was
about to have that'll do it dude she's
driving Walmart I mean a lot man my mom
goes to Walmart your mom is trash I'm
your trash who else anybody else I am
but I know I am hey back it up I go
there to observe great material at
Walmart by the way Steve will you
receive a hug from her mother you are
gonna feel really bad
listen I would say that about my own
mother yeah for a bit know what you
don't throw my mom under the [ __ ] bus
a bit for the bed I always thought don't
me under the bus not my mom
I should do I do it all the time I throw
you under the bus I believe live under
the bus where around me that's my mom
I'm gonna text her right now should all
about you take a live video meaning you
can send it to her right now I'm gonna
do it
hey Barbara you're trash don't forget to
tweet sent best-smelling laundry oh yeah
she's very a very sweet woman the [ __ ]
right every time she's holding Tiger I'm
like if I was a baby I'd fall asleep too
it looks comfortable on you because her
mom looks soft just in case you didn't
know
that's her Bob looks soft yeah anyway
thanks can you imagine if there was a
giant like if we were baby sized and
there was giants like you know
proportion-wise of a human giant what
are you saying oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
picture this I'm waiting okay there's
picture this Julian when we get tired
they pick us up hold us like this and we
get to sleep and that's that's what the
Giants love to do over a mattress no I
want someone holding medium like and
they're warm and sunny imagine like oh
no no like like they're different
Gio's mom's just all Gio's moms in any
they pick you up can't have my mom no
but they're like they're clones it's not
your real one it's they say they won't
do change at different deals you so
easily you could have Asian Gio's mom
you could have you know black Gio's mom
you
have all kinds of Jill's mom and then
you can kind of know I don't consent to
this I'll take her hair when you're not
looking but then you she holds you and
then all you get you get like nap time
with Gio's mom and she smells really
good
that'd be [ __ ] cool it would be tight
until mom was black
that's a whole different conversation no
she said black Jill's mom and I just
imagine your mom black and I'm like
that's pretty dope why is it dope just
saying you want her to make you fried
chicken southern style all kinds of
stuff
interrupting TIFF is so good I love the
show what else were you talking about
cuz I'm not hearing anything coming from
this [ __ ] side of the table all
right well we're talking about this lady
accidentally stealing a car for two
weeks oh yeah see [ __ ] cloning Gio's
mom and making her a giant is way better
but you're pretty [ __ ] small we could
just get one Pacific Islander to hold
you it's pretty easy me like you weigh
like a hundred and ten pounds yeah you
can hold her and that's it have you
heard of these cuddle things that people
just like New York things if they buy
cuddling they have them in Japan I think
in Oregon - we did an article about
Oregonians having a house that has a
cuddle peoples and people do that you
pay and maybe pretty good and they come
to you and then just [ __ ] colione
account I don't want human size regular
human size was a big person to come on
giants I saw one of these where a like a
cop who like regularly works on the beat
and [ __ ] his wife has another man come
over and cuddle her while the cop is at
work and he's chill with it because it's
just a cuddly wow and they pay him
that's pretty cool
would you do it would you know well
would it be a cuddler yeah how much is
it I mean yeah they do pretty good I
mean Joe said he would get um he would
get a guy to work in his house I thought
what the guy is doing uh and then but
the guy had to be really good-looking
pool cleaner I think was it oh no just
his housekeepers housekeeper so he says
he doesn't want any girls nope he wants
just men six-foot dude with a big dick
yeah that's a I never said big dick just
added that okay fine
but then he says
doesn't matter if they need a big dick
to clean she knows that [ __ ] attached to
it just goes around the house he said
that they have to be naked because he
doesn't want them stealing guys to
protect the house while I'm gone because
the whole point of it is I'm building a
mud hut in the backyard
and I'm gonna sleep there she's gonna
sleep in there and I was like no girls
cuz I'm not misogynistic I'm not gonna
objectify women cuz all guys want a
legion of girls cleaning up in lingerie
so true and I'm like nah dude that's not
cool and I feel more of a real man when
I control other men so I'm gonna have a
bunch of naked dudes yeah back in their
slave is not something I want to do you
want to pay them to clean out on his
dick naked yeah you're that one house on
the block that looks like it doesn't
belong it just like nice nice nice what
the [ __ ] is that a lot of naked men
going in that house yep with a mud hut
in them if we do end up getting our
coldest sack we're gonna [ __ ] put it
under a tree all right cuz I already
know this other [ __ ] it up I like it eat
your way for the Jaypee cider
yeah we need a chore I know I'm gonna
have like you know how those houses on
the side they have like all these
designs and and in pillars and [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to [ __ ] slides spinning
down like this to the entrance fallacy
and she wants to take that away from me
let's vote her off go jets off
no geo Oh Geo ok I think she's down with
it well cuz normally she's like so ready
to just kick you right between the legs
on whatever ID you have so I thought she
was dead against this early slide no no
no she that's what you think but you
don't know why no yes
she says she's down as long as I pay for
it but G you're against this why because
we know how shitty the stuff that he
comes up with so the idea and the
concepts good ok but the execution
always sucks so I'm just trying to
prevent that from our blog Yeah right
look at my office is way better than
yours and my office execution was
awesome that you don't use and ever work
in that one well what does that have to
do with execution [ __ ] don't but you
didn't do it it's [ __ ] dope it was my
idea and I made it happen
don't okay fine you're offended okay
[Music]
[Music]
Oh